[Music]
the pain is constant like the rain in
this city
i bought the dip but the dip dipped
the name's coffeezilla
and my biggest secret sometimes i wonder
if the only bottom we're gonna find
is at the bottom of a glass that's it
i'm cutting you off wait why i've only
had four or five drinks it's not about
the drinks every time you start doing
this narrator thing it's nothing but
trouble
not even my bartender understands my
brooding anymore you're doing it again
somehow maxwell can hear my narration
which is strange that's because you have
a tape recorder right there what
oh look coffee i'll play bartender one
more time but you've got to pick
yourself up after this i mean what's
this all about i just don't even see the
point markets are down inflation's up
i've got nothing but bad news what's the
rush to do another depressing story wow
that is so selfish it's all about you
isn't it do you ever think of the people
out there who subscribe to you or
they're
counting on me no
i was thinking more that they're
mildly entertained by you
oh that's the pep talk
i mild entertainment exactly you're
getting it but what you're not getting
is drinks i'm cutting you off for your
own good at least until you do another
case wait a second that that's not how
you want to play this right i mean look
i'll do another case for you but what
about this story breaking news ladies
and gentlemen maxwell the bartender is
scamming customers
not unless you want people to learn
about how you actually afforded that 10
million dollar studio i mean an actual
case
like the three euros capital story all
right all right we don't have to go
there and wait three rows capital are
you talking about that hedge fund that
blew up last month billion dollar hedge
fund and now they're on the run
you're kidding i thought they gave
themselves up nope
no one has seen them for days
and you know who that looks like a job
for yup
the police
i was thinking more of mildly
entertaining detective oh they didn't
answer your calls huh
no they screen robocallers all right you
know what i'll do it
strange as it is that's how the hunt for
3ac started
we start our story in singapore at the
front door of their office and no one's
home as you can see mail's been
collecting from all the creditors that
have been appearing trying to get their
money and crucially the founders suzu
and kyle davies of three arrows capital
are nowhere to be found which if you ask
me is pretty good timing because they
just went bankrupt they now owe people
hundreds of millions to billions of
dollars but here's the thing it wasn't
always like this only months ago these
guys were the golden boys of crypto hell
10 years ago nobody even knew who these
guys were they were just a couple of
traders in tokyo working at credit
suisse so how did they go from that and
transform themselves into one of the
world's largest crypto hedge funds and
then destroy it all in only a couple of
months well today we're going to find
out
[Music]
it was 10 years ago that the founders of
three euros capital decided they were
tired of making money for someone else
and quit their jobs to start their own
hedge fund they claim to have mostly
used their own capital to start you know
a modest sum
uh so we started with around a million
uh of personal capital and almost
immediately they were very successful
despite not having enough money to play
in the big leagues that they wanted to
get to they weren't worried three euros
capital was confident in two things
their ability to make money and their
ability to borrow it if they couldn't
make it yeah we had one period where we
had we need we desperately needed to
raise capital it was uh
prime brokers and basically one day they
came to us and said you need to have
almost twice as much money as you have
and
my mentality at the time was well just
give me like two months we i think we
made 100 return our first like month and
a half like give me two more months i'll
make it for you um
and they were like no in two weeks you
have to have that money or close your
account and so i had to get on the phone
i raised it in a weekend but i had to
get on the phone i called uh prop
trading firms in chicago and i got one
two wires funds by monday and this
attitude of pure confidence you know
either i can make you a hundred percent
in two months or i can go borrow it on a
weekend that was just kind of how they
operated and this attitude might sound
arrogant but because they were winning
it was honestly kind of contagious and
earned them quite the reputation they
became really popular for their super
bullish attitudes and became popular for
promoting something called the super
cycle in crypto the super cycle was an
idea pushed by their founder suzu who
believed that unlike most markets which
go through periods of boom and bust bull
and bear markets crypto was different
they were on the verge of mass adoption
and because of that crypto wasn't going
to go through a bear market again he
says in a tweet explaining it this is
not yet another cycle it is the end of
cycles the one where after bitcoin
flippings gold it doesn't flip back the
one where web 3 supersedes web 2. and he
would publicly say that he had
tremendous conviction in this idea that
things were only going to go up and
thought anyone who had low conviction
was quote gross to be honest so i want
you to ask yourself what would you do if
you're on a hot streak of trades you're
not afraid to borrow money and you're
convicted that the number's just gonna
go up well you might do what three euros
capital did which was borrow as much
money as you can and dump it into
bullish crypto place you know the
michael sailor idea go mortgage your
house and buy bitcoin with it only they
didn't do that because mortgaging your
house is for poor people but they did
something a little more clever three
arrows capital went to all of the
biggest crypto lenders in town from
celsius to voyager and more you know the
people we've been hearing about lately
and they told them all hey you guys know
us we're successful traders we're low
risk and we need a loan it's sort of the
equivalent of going all around town and
getting as many credit cards as you can
and maxing them all out and by the end
three euros capital had borrowed from 33
different lenders a total of not one not
two but 3.5
billion dollars and of course the
question is what are they going to do
with it well they made one of the
biggest bets of their entire life they
were going super long on the super cycle
theory except this time
turns out they were wrong crypto or
digital currencies have now lost two
trillion dollars in value holy crap i
literally just got wiped out the most
destructive wealth event in the history
of crypto with probably about 50 billion
dollars just wiped out i think this is
like a cascading effect right and i
don't think it's honestly over yet when
the crypto markets crashed in may of
2022 this led to a massive crisis for
three euros capital because all of a
sudden they weren't the prophets that
they thought they were they didn't see
it coming kyle davies says this in an
interview the tara luna situation caught
them very off guard and their lenders
noticed all of a sudden they start
approaching them saying hey we're a
little worried here can you get us our
money back and kyle davies tried to
reassure them he sent them a paper
saying they had the money i mean it
wasn't exactly a proof or anything it
was a one-page document that says they
had a net asset value of 2.3 billion
dollars which
isn't much proof at all and this was on
may 13th and it bought them about five
days before someone realized that you
can just make up numbers on papers and
send it to people and so on may 18th
some of their creditors approached them
again this time blockchain.com
they called kyle up and said hey well
maybe you can give us some of our money
back and allegedly kyle told
blockchain.com that if they recalled any
of their loans three euros capital would
boycott all their products basically
threatening them because of this
blockchain.com decided to give them a
longer time to repay fast forward
another month kyle's trying to borrow
5000 bitcoin from one lender to try to
pay a margin call to another lender
except he doesn't get it and it's at
this point that kyle finally starts
admitting to some of the lenders that if
crypto markets keep declining they
wouldn't be okay so naturally what do
all these lenders do well um they panic
and try to get their money out but this
time is different instead of picking up
the phone as usual with their confident
responses of oh we have the money or if
we don't have the money we're going to
double our money in two months anyways
there's no answer at all instead all
they get is this a tweet from suzu we
are in the process of communicating with
relevant parties and are fully committed
to working this out but the insiders
knew this wasn't true torreira's capital
wasn't in touch with anyone it was like
they had vanished off the face of the
earth one of their close associates said
they had ghosted people and because of
this these lenders who now are left with
3.5 billion dollars missing now started
to collapse themselves and have their
own problems we've already talked about
this with voyager and celsius just to
name a few and their last hope is to
figure out where in the world these guys
are with all of their money and they
could truly be anywhere because
as they declared bankruptcy rumors
started to come out that maybe three
arrows capital had been a little naughty
with their money according to reports
the duo had bought a series of mansions
and a 50 million dollar super yacht
which according to a signed affidavit
this yacht was intended to be larger
than any yacht owned by any singapore
billionaire which is a strange flex
coming from guys who now weren't
billionaires and since i know you're
probably curious what a 50 million
dollar super yacht looks like
if you're okay with it we'll take a tour
of it as i explain what happens next so
if you just come aboard for a second the
52 steel san lorenzo you get 52 meters
of stunning views and swimming pools
which is all allegedly purchased with
borrowed money top it all off with
stunning dining rooms a full gym but in
my opinion the main attraction here is
this 2019 tweet from their new owner
suzu
climate change talk is cheap but sailing
the seven seas on your yacht as an
international fugitive is expensive it's
almost like he was dropping hints the
whole time but like i said we don't even
know if he's on this yacht as an
international fugitive or if he's in one
of his other super mansions because
let's not forget when he wasn't on this
yacht he was busy living in a
multi-million dollar bungalow that his
three-year-old owned which i guess i
haven't explained yet suzu is the father
of a multi-millionaire baby this is all
because there's a trust in his name that
owns their multi-million dollar bungalow
but obviously suzu bought this house in
the three-year-old's name so why do it
this way well speculation says that
bankruptcy courts probably can't get
access to it if it's in a trust and
that's not all three euros capital has
hired lawyers that have been allegedly
advising them on how to help shield
those assets from creditors according to
the signed affidavit which combined with
the fact that nobody knows where these
guys are things are looking pretty dim
and all of this is just so sad in my
opinion not just because they might get
away with it but because all this money
that they owe isn't just a number on a
screen billions of dollars whatever
it's really the bill that's coming due
for regular investors all due to the
arrogance of two traitors and the
carelessness of these lending platforms
who gave it to them because let's not
get it twisted suzu and kyle davies were
initially playing with their own money
before all these crypto lenders gave
them a bunch more of it so it's not as
if there's only one bad guy here i mean
how could these lenders not do more due
diligence on the people they're lending
customer money to i mean kyle davies was
literally sending one page pdfs that
said that they had 2.3 billion dollars
and people just believed him so that's
on the one hand the crypto lenders are
at fault but of course on the other hand
it's pretty clear that three arrows
capital wasn't honest with the lenders
either and i could do the whole pitch
for regulation here but i'm kind of sick
of doing that because you guys know that
the real truth of it though is the ones
that are actually going to pay for all
this pay for these yachts are the
regular investors who put their
hard-earned money into these lending
platforms that now are bankrupt but even
in the best case scenario if they
cooperate i guarantee the real winners
are going to be the lawyers and suzu and
kyle davies were already trying to make
claims against their own company that
they are owed money anyways that's
basically the three euros capital story
case closed
well that's one down thousands more to
go but
strangely enough i feel different
maybe maxwell was right about needing to
work again or maybe it's just because
the sun's coming out
either way
things are looking a bit brighter